us präsident donald trump hat seine
kritik an den medien verschärft mit der
vergabe von preisen für seiner meinung
nach falsche berichterstattung auf der
internetseite der republikanischen
partei führte trump am mittwoch zehn
gewinner der von ihm selbst ausgerufenen
fake news awards auf platz eins landet
die new york times weil sie am tag der
wahl trumps erklärt habe dass sich die
wirtschaft niemals von dem neuen
präsidenten erholen werde
platz vier etwa erreichte eine büste
martin luther kings die doch nicht aus
dem open office entfernt worden sei wie
von time berichtet auf platz elf führte
trump zudem nicht eine konkrete
geschichte auf sondern allgemein die
berichterstattung über angebliche
absprachen zwischen russland und trams
wahlkampfteam
trotz allem gebe es aber auch reichlich
gute nachrichten auf die das
amerikanische volk stolz sein könne so
trump auf twitter